so is it tasha or natasha
it's tasha tasha so tasha uh tasha
where'd you grow up where are you from
i'm from i'm i'm from chicago but i grew
up in long beach california
long beach and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
um yeah i had both of my parents up to
until the age of seven
then at seven my mom brought us out here
from chicago
train one late night my dad came home
and found
out his family was going to california
and so we came out here and i started
growing up in long beach
and how was your childhood it was all
right it was a it was oh i had a good
childhood in a bad childhood because i
chose all the wrong things
um i started using drugs really early at
the age of 16 and it went bad from there
on
any like child abuse no not really
no not really no you avoided that no i
didn't get child abuse i was abused
sexual abuse but i wasn't child abuse i
wasn't beaten when you say sexually
abused by who yeah i got best elected
about a couple of my uncles on my
father's side
when you were old when i was like six
six and seven i remember
and how long did that go on that goes
that went off for like a year
and then we moved away so then after
that was
it so how'd your life go after
huh as a teenager how was your life i
mean what kind of kid were you in high
school
um real bad i fought a lot i followed
out in school
i didn't study like i should because i
wanted to be into gangs so i did more
into games
i sell drugs when i was in school i got
kicked out early for selling marijuana
i went to long beach jordan i got kicked
out and then i went to the hutch
that's the lowest you can go after you
go to get kicked out of long beach
school so i went to the hutch for a
little while and then i ended up getting
kicked out of the air
so my life was just on the run after
that
and when did prostitution become it
became
at the age of like 18 to support my
habit which was correct
yes and uh
how did that begin did you work with a
pimp or no i didn't grow up with a pimp
i was always into doing my own things
but i grew up around pimps and hoes
so i saw a lot and i learned a lot just
like
watching the things that the other girls
would go through
scared me enough to the point where i
didn't want no pimp
you know so i did mostly i did my own
thing but i had a lot of problems with
pimps because i didn't wouldn't choose
you know so um but i avoided that
by the grace of god i avoided that but
i've seen a lot of bad things happen
yeah to a lot of girls did you have some
rough experiences
oh yes i remember one time when um
i was like i said i had to be at least
about maybe about 21 at this time and uh
i went to the park and i see a couple of
my homeboys in the park and my homework
came up to me and told me that
it was a white boy in the park and a lot
of money that was his friend that he was
real cool
and he wanted to kick it with somebody
so i told him about you i said okay well
i'll go with him
so then i end up meeting a white boy i
go with the white boy we go we get
something we get we call
a cab and he lives in like the white
part of long beach so it's kind of nicer
over there in this area here so we go to
his house which he
he lives in a condo and we go upside i
remember going up the stairs and i
remember passing by these other two
condos but the doors were
open right so i can't remember like
certain things so as i go up the stairs
we go to his house and everything
so i'm sitting in the living room and um
he gave me a
a a box full of marijuana right so he
says go ahead and roll your
butt you know when i get back you know
be ready when i come back out the
bathroom so i rolled his joint up
and so when he came out to bed told me
he had a gun pointed at me
and he told me that this was a dying
thing today was the day that we was
gonna die
you know and the only way
the only way that i would be able to
live if i could make his dick hard
and that's the only thing that would
save me so
to make a long story short he came over
there you know to where i was at maybe
take off all my clothes he took up all
his clothes and he wrote a
suicide note because he said once he
killed me he was going to kill himself
so i deal with everything i did
everything he asked me to do you know
nothing worked his penis still wouldn't
get hard so i knew i was going to die
after that
so i asked him before you know he's
killed us can i use the bathroom you
know whatever he said well go ahead and
go in the bathroom
so while i'm in the bathroom i'm looking
around like at the windows to see if
there's
any kind of window i can jump out of
anything but i see nowhere i can get out
so i flesh the toilet like i used to bow
to and he kept saying come on out of
there come on out of there it's time so
when i come out the bathroom
all i can remember is him reaching his
point of his gun at me
and shooting but i guess he was high he
was off balance so cause he missed
when the bullets went over my head and
some kind of way i got to screech and
run out the door
open up the door and run out the door
and when i and i was running
i ran through this lady house she had
our door open
and i never forget i just opened up the
lady's door snatched the door open
ran past the lady ran in her bedroom and
ran up on her bed
and got up under her bed and she like
i can hear her screaming to her son uh
come out to the bathroom there's a naked
lady under the bed
and a son he came out the bed so he was
like maybe his mom was tripping or
something right
and he looked under the bed and he seen
me and then i was telling him that
the next door neighbor is trying to kill
me
so they called the police and the police
told all of us to just stay down on
you know on the ground on the floor you
know what i'm saying
and it made me stay on the farm until
the police came right
so he must have went outside looking for
me
because when he went outside he didn't
have nothing on but his shirt
but his pants and when he went outside
and looked for me i was in the
neighbor's house he didn't know that i
was in the neighbor's house
so he came on downstairs by that time
the long beach police department had the
whole place surrounded
he pointed his gun at the police and
long beach police shot this man 18 times
and he didn't die so make a long story
short so after they shot him they told
me
they told me on the phone that there's
gonna be a knock on the door and it's
gonna be two officers and for me to go
outside with the officer i'll never
forget the lady
because i didn't have no clothes the
lady gave me a pair of underwear i'll
never forget a bed long pierced
um yellow socks never forget them yellow
socks and the movement was put on
covering my body up because i was naked
when i came in the house
and the police came and knocked on the
door and got me
and they took me to a long beach
memorial hospital you know to do the
rape thing and everything
and i had these detectives to come to
see me and [ __ ] and they they let me go
home they was asking me if i had
somebody to stay
if i because they needed me you know in
case the man didn't die or something
don't need me to go to court and stuff
you know but by me being in the streets
in the drugs the last thing i want to do
is
have anything to do with the police or
anything like that you know i was just
so glad that i didn't die and they saved
me
so much and much had went on by right
and i had stopped going to talk to the
detectives and everything
and one night i never forget it was
raining one night and my stepmother you
know she was a drunk she used to be all
around me and they were hanging out in
front of liquor stores
so the police was riding around they had
my picture
and they must have ran across my
step-mom and told my stepmom that
when they looking for me it's very
important that they that they see me and
so
uh i was so happy to be in the house
that day she when she came home she
never even told me the police was
looking for me because if she hadn't
told me i would have left i wouldn't
have been here
so it was raining at night and all the
homies kicked it at her house so
nothing was a bunch of games it was just
[ __ ] it's raining we all in the house
watching movies because it's raining
outside you know
and it was these two big white boys
knocking on the door and i never forget
it
and they knocked on the door and one of
my friends that was at the house
after the door and they said they was
looking for natasha grant which is me
and so they told me to talk to me the
police said you listen you're not
you're not under arrest you're not going
to jail or nothing the detective just
needs to talk to you
about you know the man that got shot to
rape you you know and everything and
they just need you to come down
and you're gonna let you go so i'm
thinking okay i'll go
so i said can i put on some clothes
first you know cause it's raining and
they let me pull off some clothes
and i went with you i went with them to
long beach jail
i ended up staying in long beach jail
for two months before i even talked to a
detective
they locked me up as a civil content
until the day i could go to court and
testify against the man because he never
died
he lived so i had to go to court to
testify in front of him in front of the
judge
you know what he did to me and
everything so once i did that once i
went to court and i seen this man again
and when i seen this man like i got
chills all over my body
because just thinking that this man is
gonna kill me and himself
but i made it through that and so i
testified in court and that day then
they let me go
they let me go after that so that
traumatized me for a long time after
that you know after that
experience with this man that
traumatized me so
then i ended up going to prison a little
bit after that you know
and i did out i was on parole i was on
football 13 years i couldn't get off
parole for nothing in the world
whenever i get in and go to jail i go to
jail for just a little stupid [ __ ] and i
get out
i go back i get out because my mind was
gone after that you know what i'm saying
and the only thing that could to clear
my head is for me to
i think you know just get high just
cover all that in
you know what i'm saying so
anything else you have to ask me do you
have children i have one son
and you raised him no my mom raised him
i couldn't raise you're on the street
yeah about choice i didn't have to be
you know what i mean
but i chose to be out there in the
street because that's what i figured
that's
that's what i had fun at you know i said
i had fun
all the drama the drama was what's well
i think was more funner than high itself
you know what i'm saying being around
i've heard that a lot where a lot of
people say they're addicted to the
the drama yeah it was working on the
street right yeah the drugs themselves
yeah that's why i had fun at so that's
why i stayed out there
so long in the streets i'm 52 years old
today
today's your birthday no not today's
night birthday but i'm just saying in
general yeah
do you get you get depressed or down
sometimes yes i have a
pstd right now i have backslashes and
nightmares you know sometimes i'm scared
sometimes i think people
really follow me sometimes i get scared
thinking somebody's gonna get me because
i'm happy and i'm nervous you know what
i mean like
you know i don't know because the wrong
i have done because i've not
been no angel but uh i guess it now is
catching up to me because i
got so much older now you know what i
mean what is did you start using crack
i was 16. 16. are you still using today
yes i like to be honest with you i don't
want to lie
yeah no if you're down here that's kind
of it's kind of hard
it's hard not to it's hard but but i can
say that i'm a better person than i am
today than i was then like things that
i've done then i wouldn't do today
you know i um i i'm more responsible you
know i have my own place i pay my own
bills now
you know what i'm saying i take care of
myself earlier
you know what i mean i'm just you know
how do you think
this lifestyle has changed you living in
the streets it made me appreciate and
people realized
that um i'm not better than nobody do
you understand what i'm saying
that now that i got my feet uh uh
that i'm doing a little better for
myself that if i see
somebody that was in my situation that i
won't judge
them i would help them do you understand
what i'm saying
to them where it was a time when i
thought i was better than them when i
wasn't [ __ ] either
and i would judge them like i was better
and i wasn't
but today i know you know what i mean if
i see a girl that needs something
somebody might need a dollar too and i
got it you know what i'm saying i would
give it
you feel me um today i would go
shopping for myself pay my bills first
take care of my hygienes and stuff as a
woman's supposed to do and then i'll do
whatever's left you know what i'm saying
but yeah it's changed me a lot
made me a better person actually i think
i think it made my heart a lot better
because i was bitter that's interesting
yeah
what advice would you give to a young
woman who's
kind of enticed by the the street life
to stop because you know you may not
make it you may not make it
to be my age you know what i'm saying to
stop right now and listen to what people
tell
you and go to if you go the other way
because see
i was just fortunate that that i'm still
hearing that i still got my mind
and i ain't went all the way crazy but i
did enough [ __ ] to make me just as crazy
as that woman
sitting over there talking to herself
and can't even realize
that she didn't voted on herself i could
be in that same situation you may not
make it
so the best thing to do is listen to you
know what i'm saying and change your
life right now
because life is precious and before you
know the years it's gone just like that
and you'd be wake up one day you're 60
years old and you'd be like damn what
happened
and i cuz you didn't listen and i didn't
either but i learned the hard way
these these last years i got i was
trying to live into the best of my
ability
you know with no regrets you have no
regrets from
i have none do you think that your
childhood
had been different that maybe your life
would be different today
i'm not going to say that because a lot
of people have a good childhood and they
still in this
position here that's true you know
because i chose all the bad decisions
because i knew right from wrong and i
wanted to go wrong you tell me don't go
you tell me to go right and don't go
left i'm going left
because something must be very
interesting left so i want to go see
what's popping over there you know
like you said don't go to that house
that's the bad house right there
as soon as i get a chance i'm going
right down to that house what
because it's cracking you know so that's
all that was my
i made bad decisions that's all are you
living on the street no
where are you at i stay coastal street
at the ford oh you're at the ford hotel
yeah it's apartment yeah it's nice yeah
this apartment is giving us
to show people that out in the street
has been irresponsible
to show themselves how to start back
living again
and a lot of people from there they move
to apartments you know one bedrooms two
bedrooms
you gotta crawl before you walk were you
living on the street at one point
yes of course
in the fort is kind of a step between
that yeah but i was sleeping but see
the only difference is and i'll try to
be better nobody i was not living in
on the street in l.a i was living in the
street in long beach
you know what i'm saying when i've been
living in the street living from house
to house
i've i literally had literally i have
not never really literally
lived out in the street you know what
i'm saying like
outside right i've always had a house of
people houses that i could go to just
crash wherever you can yeah yeah
you know sometimes you have to pay to
you know pay to stay whatever you know
what i'm saying but
i've never had to be literally outside
what are you doing for money now
i'm on ssi right now okay so i'm okay
takes the pressure off you to do that
yeah i don't have to do all that stuff
anymore pace my bills
and everything you know i'm doing i'm a
lot better now
i might i put it like this here my story
is really to let people know that you
can't change you can't get better
you know you can if you want to
you know todd shuffle thank you so much
for talking with me and uh
you're welcome good luck with wherever
you go from here thank you thank you it
was nice to meet you too
you too darling i finally got in here to
do an interview with you
i've been trying to get here with you
forever
you